-Well, you know,
"The Good Place,"
again, was a show --
and I know when everybody
auditioned for it,
it was fake scripts, because
unlike a lot of sitcoms,
you know, there were
a lot of turns in the show
a lot of cliffhanger endings
When you knew you were doing
the show in the very beginning
did you have trouble
explaining it to people?
Were you worried you were gonn
tip off what the idea was?
-You're outing me.
Yeah, it was like -- if you have
seen it, if you haven't,
there's a big twist
at the end of the first episod
where you think I'm workin
for the God Squad,
and really I am a demon
torturing them.
-Yeah.
-And it was a great flip
that really got everyone
energized who was watching it.
So we were told,
"Please do not tell anybody.
In fairness,
they said that after
what I'm about to describe
-You told a bunch of people.
-I went to --
you know John Krasinksi.
-Wonderful guy.
-Wonderful guy,
and worked with Mike Shore
as well, on "The Office."
And I'm a little
competitive with him.
I only compete with people who
I can't possibly ever win with
-Yeah, yeah.
-I find that more...
stimulating or something.
I don't know. So, I was --
I'm very competitive with John
in this great way, and I -
He's going off
to make a big action movie
and he said,
"What are you doing?"
And I went,
"Oh, I'm about to work
with one of your buddies,
Mike Shore,"
and I play, kind of,
middle management
in 'The Good Place,'
it's called,
in the afterlife."
And I could see his eyes go,
"Oh, yeah, 'The Office,'
but in heaven.
Yeah, I got it. I got it."
[ Laughter ]
And I went
"No, [mumbles]. No.
It turns out that
I'm actually a demon
at the end of the first season."
And I saw him light up and go,
"Oh, that's interesting."
I go, "Yeah!"
[ Laughter ]
Uh, I want to ask you abou
"Curb," which is so fantastic,
'cause you play
yourself on "Curb,"
and I know Larry's
a dear friend of yours,
so it must, at times,
just not feel like work at all
-Correct.
-Yet he did something very -
very cruel...
-Yeah, yeah.
-...which is he made
you and Mary --
on "Curb,"
you guys are divorced.
-Yeah.
-And we would get --
we'd get calls
from friends we'd had dinner
with, like, a month before
going, "Oh..."
[ Laughter ]
You know, you felt like saying
"Yeah, yeah,
all big, serious events,
we like to announce
on the Larry David show."
-Yeah.
Well, he's -- of all
your friends, he's the most --
You know, he's the most
emotionally connected, Larry
If you had a big divorce
in your life,
you would definitely want
Larry to tell people.
-You know, actually,
Mary once said to him, you know,
"If I was ever in real trouble
you'd be one of the first people
I would call,"
and it almost made him cry
-Really?
-Yes, and she meant it.
-Go figure.
-Wow.
-He would be the last person..
-I would -- and I can't believ
his reaction was crying
and not him saying, like,
"I don't want you to call me."
-I know, right, yes.
Well, he was caught off guard.
-Yeah.
One piece of really exciting
news, which is, it's sad.
"The Good Place" is coming
to a close, but you, uh --
You already have
your next show lined up.
-Yes, yes, yes.
You're doing a show on NBC
with Tina Fey...
-Tina Fey.
-...as the creator,
and Robert Carlock,
her great partner.
-Right, actually
I've spent some time with them
Everyone says
"Tina Fey and Robert Carlock."
-Yeah.
-It's Robert Carlock.
-He's just -- I've known him
a long time.
Yeah, I would say they're equal,
because I'm afraid
of both of them.
Yeah, so I like
to put them equal pedestals.
-I know for a fact
they don't watch your show
so that's why I could say that
[ Laughter ]
-Well, there's no way I'm gonn
beat that for a closer.
Ted Danson, everyone.